the year of 1997 some people would say
that at the beginning of a new hong kong
but to me i think it's more like the
beginning of an
end 25 years since the british hanover
of hong kong to china those born in 1997
have witnessed rapid social and
political change
we spoke to three young hong kongers
about the city's evolution
i think a lot of young adults like
myself we're all feeling the same thing
because
those opportunities that were offered to
the previous generation are no longer
available to us
is it harder to find a job in the
circumstances that we're in now yeah
obviously but
there's also a lot of external factors
affecting it too
i think
1997 was the beginning of an end that
we'll see
how hong kong would descend into the
chaos or the city that we're seeing
right now
a city that is without freedom without
democracy and also without the trust of
the people
from sars in 2003 through the 2008
beijing olympics the 2014 umbrella
movement and the 2019 pro-democracy
protest
the hong kong of 2022 is now a very
different environment
i was always very frustrated by when
they refer to us as this bright future
of hong kong or the next generation
but really how much has the government
done for us you can see that an
overwhelming majority of hong kongers we
really
want democracy but what we got was just
deaf years from the government and the
government telling you
literally that you're not a stakeholder
of the society i would say that one of
the biggest changes i've seen is that
you know hong kong is
as a whole is getting more and more
closed off
slowly like gradually gradually you know
people are censoring themselves
from you know openly talking about
topics that for most of the people in
the world seems normal
hong kong now marks the halfway point
and its 50-year transition to chinese
rule
with china tightening its grip on the
territory does this generation still see
its future here
we go
of course i would consider going back to
hong kong and i think that is
the driving force uh for me every single
day every single morning i wake up and
then i realize i'm not at home and i
cannot go home i cannot go home to see
the people i love and then i would think
oh then i need to do something i better
do something to make sure that i can get
home one day if hong kong remains the
same way it is currently where
opportunities are favorable to me yeah i
don't see why not i don't see why i
would leave but at the same time
when that changes
and when i don't have reason to stay in
hong kong i will definitely leave so in
a 10 year to 25 years that's really hard
to say if you say you know five to ten
years
possibly
[Music]
you